[音楽]
今じゃ
白色ですワールドカップが終わってからサッカー年前すごい出てきました
そして己&長友選手を約束したもう一度ちゃんと練習して闘おう等
ん
準備で3時間の練習したいんですけども2に策だと練習をしてても間違いなくあのう
ぶっ
サッカー苦手なんですよ作家逃げないで藤坂ね写真の僕はきっと上手くなれないじゃあ
どうすればいいのか普通のサッカーのトレーニングの何かを退任するだけで梅の香が得
られると思うんですよ普通のサッカーボールと大きさの要因1705倍の大きさの
サッカーボールを準備しました
こちらです刷毛でみましょう約75万円必要なサッカーボールの大きさは良い服なぜ怖
さーんレンズなのでその身長とほぼ川にぐらいのサッカーボール
普通のサッカーボールの475万円サッカーボール盛んで別所する部分で僕は普通の
サッカーボールで練習するより1175版の練習量成果を得られると思うんで僕は普通
の人間のサッカー勉強してるけど if a
おっおおっ受けませんマッハ
まあ本当にでかいじゃんこれをどうやってくるんだろうまた衝撃的にで稼げるよ
いけるガーン
tee
やばい ana
嫁
ています
頑張って
部屋から出せねぇねぇ
ますぜひやったら俺あーなんか童貞して潰さんだよ練習してもう1回前編の中ってな
またバイバイだよねー
nome
wh
ええええええ
ああああああああ
キヌア
ですわー
car
1ん
ええええええ
あっはっは
アーサーじゃないまずグレー3年それができません
まーすリボびっくりだった
首バキって言ったあー
いいいいん
me
dare
3位
dj ino
ああああああ
3-1
すればいいん
ああああああん
です
ん
voodoo
うまっ派
1ですねこれだーーーっ
me
dea
car
ana あっ